but what's the holdup then what's
slowing things down as you mentioned
Anna the arms embargo seems to be one of
the last remaining stumbling blocks
preventing world powers and Iran from
sealing a deal Iran wants the embargo
lifted immediately it says it needs you
know new arms in order to help it with
the fight against Islamic state and to
that end it is backed by the Russians
were who would potentially be a major
arms supplier to Iran's also provoked a
bit of a a split if you like on the
usually unified front presented by world
powers because of course the u.s. is
somewhat reluctant to lift the arms
embargo against Iran although it has
shown a modicum of flexibility regarding
the duration and nature of that embargo
but of course the u.s. is major regional
allies here are Israel and Saudi Arabia
both of whom counter or put Iran at the
top of their I supposed enemy list and I
suppose the u.s. also concerned about
any fresh arms to Iran finding their way
to the likes of Hezbollah or Hamas and
being used against Israel but given all
the other hurdles that they've overcome
during these marathon talks it seems
that perhaps there is some way that that
both sides can come to some
accommodation on that issue as well Anna
so with that in mind Elliot what happens
next what's the next stage yeah well
look we know that the deadline was
actually what 6am Vienna time that's
midnight Washington time now that has
come and gone now if Congress did not
receive a text message by that time by
midnight Washington time then that than
they would have been seen to have missed
that deadline enough so far as we're
aware no text message was center which
means that that review period will be
doubled now from one month to two months
for the US Congress if and when any
final agreement is reached but to US
Secretary of State John Kerry was keen
to emphasize that it's it's it's the
most important thing is is the what of
any deal rather than when it's actually
achieved but he did also add that they
will he will not sit at the negotiating
table forever we will not brush and we
will not be rushed and we won't let
ourselves be rushed through any aspect
of this
all that we are focused on is the
quality of the agreement and that is
what will continue to define our work
I'm at least is something that the u.s.
and the Iranians very much agree on the
Iranian Foreign Minister tweeting we are
working hard but not rushed to get the
job done mark my words you can't change
horses in the middle of a stream and so
long as well powers in Iran is still in
that stream and still negotiating then
there is of course the possibility the
deal will be done it could be perhaps
imminent perhaps over the weekend
perhaps they'll take a break and come
back to these talks but the talks
although they fail to miss yet another
deadline the talks are not dead just yet
Anna